[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today JT starts
this hour off in Dallas hi JT what's
up hey how's it going Dave what's up
George hey uh congrats to do Dr deloney
too thank you how can we help
today yeah so me and my fiance are
preparing to buy a house in Dallas and
basically my my question is I'm kind of
worried if I'm over
spending on my
mortgage and so the house is worth 350
350,000 um I think it's a great deal U
mortgage interest PMI all that good
stuff would be
2840 and our combined income
monthly if we're just because we both
work in sales if we're just saying our
salaries that's 7,400 if we do our
salary plus 50 % of commission it's
around 12,000 post tax a month okay is
this on a 15year
fixed it's not that's the that's the one
yeah I'd put it on 15E fixed or I
wouldn't do it and I think you can
afford to do that and still do it within
these numbers um however you're you're
speaking as if you're already married
and you're not when do you get
married our wedding is is dated for May
okay you do not buy the house prior to
May okay cuz you're going to own a house
with someone you're not married
to and so you don't have a combined
income and dude you're talking to
somebody who's been doing this 35 years
I've had the horrible stories of we
bought the house together but we didn't
make it to the alter together for
whatever
reason yeah talk about an ugly
breakup or I'll tell you an even
horrible one and this will never happen
to you JT but just to let you know I'm
not just pulling this out of my uh hat
uh the uh uh actually talk to one guy um
he owned a house with his
fiance's mother because she was killed
in a car wreck before the
wedding and all of her assets went to
her family so now he's pardners with his
passed away horrible tragedy fiance's
mother in a home talk about awkward
messy don't do this dude wait on after
for May you've got plenty of time in
your life to buy a house you are not
required to buy a house right now and
y'all got house fever you've gone out
looking at houses you've already picked
this house out you might even have this
house under contract do
you I do oh boy it's like he's done this
before I do I'm sorry JT I would not
close on this house I would tell these
folks I'm going to give you my Earnest
my going walk away and and your fiance
is going to look at you like you have
one eye in the center of your head but
um yeah you you know I I am not
predicting a breakup or certainly not
predicting her death I hope none of
those things happen I don't think they
will but you are in no hurry you the
only thing you got in a hurry about is
buying a house you can get in a hurry
about getting
married we where's the urg you we could
solve this you could just go and get
married yeah I mean we could get married
and go to court is there a big is there
a big wedding planned like a huge big
deal there is a wedding plan yeah
yeah okay if if you went and got legally
married I I'll bless it I I would say do
it but I I I'm going to beg you not to
close on a home with someone that you
don't you are not legally married to um
just because you're you're leaving all
kinds of potential problems and um and
then go ahead and have the wedding a lot
of people do that these days apparently
I hear more and more I've run into that
more and more that like I'll be sitting
there at a wedding and they'll go know
it's not the real wedding what do you
mean I'm here I drove all the way over
here what do you mean it's not the real
wedding no it's a they got married like
four months ago and this is this dog and
pony show yeah like God who does that
well a lot of people these days I I
don't know this stuff okay so whatever
it's okay I old school I'm just I I
thought when you were had a wedding you
got married but I didn't it's a new
thing so it's okay hey if if you do that
JT I would I just don't want you to get
in a a problem and um you don't and for
those of you that are just shacking up
don't buy a house with your shack up or
whatever you call them okay don't do
that either same problem okay breaking
up is hard to do but if you own a house
together it's freaking impossible well
the fact that JT called after he's
already on contract saying ah here's the
numbers I'm trying to justify it it
tells me he's even going late I don't
feel good about this what do I do yeah I
think your numbers are okay your timing
sucks